here
cool so we have some things to do
I want to look at the sweeps hey
linky did I see the thing crash again
let me see
bot no back
up
[Music]
o very nice
you're spending so much effort on this
end curses thing I'm surprised like you
know just getting a simple tile map is
really
easy it's only when you start doing the
smoothing stuff that it gets hard
what
Ah that's kind of
they're definitely good runs in
here hyper bam sweeps are just a little
I'm pretty sure the experiment
uh the GP is taking
forever there too many data points in
it be pretty weird but
I think we're going to have a nice chill
evening and I'm going to figure out
uh some stuff with the
sweets I've got these These are
amazing athletic Brewing
Company these are
non-alcoholic half a% alcohol like 60
calories they're just like they taste
like actually good beers
it looks like this thing just straight
up didn't
sample like subst regions here so what
we're going to do for this we'll take
this on one
here
all drag this over and drag this
over
Okay so
here we can see this
one much much more quickly gets to max
four it does have higher initial cost so
actually this sweep of ours should have
been very quick it only wasn't quick
because of the Gan process
Shenanigans which I thought were the
same but something is definitely scy
there
see yeah these things don't take an hour
but they're taking an hour to
launch
somehow so probably the gaussian process
being
screwy this has a lower floor on total
time
steps that could explain some of the
difference this immediately jumps up to
Max learning rate which is very weird
I actually wouldn't know why it would do
that that's very
odd I think we had a separate scale on
this
maybe and then
gamma yeah all these scales are very
weird I'm just kind of
okay this one actually didn't explore
update EPO at all
either it did get BPT Horizon which ours
gets as
well uh and it got numm which we don't
get here and it has this nice parito
front interestingly it actually didn't
get this point over here that we
got then mini batch
size we do explore mini bat size a
bit and we actually find better results
on this mini bat a little
bit so I guess we look at
Dev we look for culprits
so here is the default
config we will also pull up here
actually this one will have the default
and then we'll look
at
sweep I think I just set everything to
0.
five by
default except for
time so by comparison
okay most of these
are5 ones that were 0.25 BPT Horizon and
actually I think num
M's was num M set
too it was set to 0.
five so this is actually the same as
before in fact pretty much all of this
is be the same as before
changed me time steps changed that
matter though
think that would
matter because none of the problems that
I see
yeah this is literally I just bumped up
a couple of these
prams that should not make a
difference so either something yeah
something else must have changed
right didn't think I've run a good sweep
in a while on that
maybe uh there will be a clue in here
somewhere
you're not going to get Hardware usage
actually
right these are plenty
fast you're not going to get Hardware
usage out of
is there it is right
there found
it that's the
bug it's also probably what was screwing
us
we can rerun and now stuff will
work rerun both of
actually that was easier than
expected that was very stupid of me for
these are Auto
scaled so we will put these
on on manual
bug very
nice and uh we will leave that to
bad that was kind of too
quick I expected that to take longer
I mean we'll get the uh the e3b Box soon
enough so we'll be able to run more
sweets is anything on the
Discord no not
running could try to get kinetics
running
oh man you guys didn't ship a pit
package
guys you did all this work and didn't
ship a pit package
fine we'll F we'll fiddle with it
anyways
I don't know why the heck this would be
uh
[Music]
don't give me code examples that don't
run that don't have
Imports damn it
where are they getting these things from
my gosh
is there a way to just have it randomly
sample
ridiculous kind of funny that they
reimplemented a bunch of like the
canonical
it's this one is the one we want TR Funk
with list of
levels
annoying hey miac how's it
[Music]
drive me
crazy you going to drive me
crazy as usual longer work
days yeah that's how it goes
that's how it
goes that ought to be decent enough
right
heck oh wait hold
on he kinetics
M fun
name how's this
work
okay well I think I will
uh I'll let them handle this
I'll let them handle uh their
own packaging
all
right said to send some quick
messages
cool yeah so this is a little more
I need to push this to S can I actually
can I hack
around get eval
hey how's it
going we are uh fiddling with kinetics
at the moment uh I promis Jacob
forester's lab some compatibility
patches as part of a new collaboration
at nurs and then I got pneumonia and
then I never did it so I'm doing that
now um and it looks
like some of the Jack stuff is
stabilized a little bit which is good
but uh there are still some things
missing in
here that's where we're at at the
moment um kinetics has the potential to
actually be
usable you know not many people are
actually and when I say not many I mean
nobody is actually releasing M's as fast
as puffer except this one maybe maybe
this one's fast enough we'll see
I hate Jacks I honestly I not used it
really properly before and I thought I
didn't like it and now I'm actually
having to use it and I hate it this is
horrible like people think that this is
actually like clever and like the way
for it it's so incredibly stupid
here not that bad it's pretty performant
for a python DSL but here's the thing
dsls
um yeah that's so
sketchy all
thing here look all I have to do in
order to convince you that
um the jack is stupid
here here's an actually good repository
written by one of the most talented
people I know this is what Jack makes
them
write ready
craft
X then we go
to
baselines and then we just go to like
their
Po and then we just scroll down and
watch this [ __ ] at the top
accumulate oh we're four deep nested can
we go for five yep oh that's six deep
nested right
there is it five or six oh now we're six
wait one two three yeah six
functions this is horrible
code this is bad and you should feel bad
about
this I mean this is literally Google
Bros Reinventing programming for
absolutely no [ __ ] reason other than
to make everyone miserable
horrible and like oh it's really
performant distributed shut up you could
have made something performant
distributed without doing
this
differx is also like
this ah don't do it stop
why see the crazy thing about this is
like I could have written this entire
thing in see in probably about a third
of the code and about a tenth of the
pain like literally this guy went and
reimplemented his entire project in
JavaScript just so that he could get
like cool browser demos I would have
just gotten those for free
like look at this this is very low
Fidelity physics this does not need to
be GPU
simulated it's great work mind you I
mean this guy is one of the best people
I know at the moment in RL but it's just
like it hurts to see this because I know
how much more work this was than it had
to be
basic yeah exactly and here's the crazy
thing he started with a C library box 2D
is is a good fast C library for this
that he then ported to ja so that the
whole thing could run on Jack instead of
just writing the M's and
C it would have been so much easier to
just leave the m and C
vectorization uh I think that they're
doing that in
gymnasium because I gave them I gave
them the goahead to go do that as long
as they keep the puffer name on the back
end um but like I don't see why I should
be the one to do
that right
the thing is that like as fast as our
vectorization
is we barely even need it anymore like
our new puffer are so fast you can run
them on One Core and you have maybe 10%
overhead most of the time like most of
our M's we run them on like two cores
back and forth just so that it's async
and then it's like zero overhead but
like rm's are so fast you barely even
have to do that
yeah the ecosystem is fragmented but the
is I'm sick of trying to patch stuff
right like it's the code is so bad it's
just I'm going to just replace most of
it that's
all why I [ __ ]
Jacks and the thing is like this is
actually code by somebody I respect and
somebody who is good at what they do
okay so the fact that this is [ __ ] isn't
their fault it's Jack
I can't even like I literally can't even
patch this it's so
thing M
State
replay I guess that's not terrible we
could do it this
way let's try this
one driv me
mess sample random
level set to level
would there be any benefit to moving all
of puffer to
see
um I guess that I would never have to
talk to people who write horrible python
code
again but also I don't think I'd get
many users with the PC library to be
honest it would basically the only
reason to ever do that if I were to use
like it would have to at least be some
C++ because torches that or you'd have
to use tensor flow C which is
ass with python well that's what do you
think it
is I mean the environment and see for
our native M's the vectorization doesn't
do anything and then the learning is in
torch which
is is uh C backend bindings or C++ back
end right
nativization that doesn't get used for
our new M's at
all like the like the uh emulation code
you
mean like that doesn't get used for our
new M at all the puffer stack is really
thin for the new M's it's like new M's
tiny little compatibility wrapper so it
looks like a Becken clean puff oral like
the training stack is less than 2,000
lines
any major gains I'll go just good code
well no there's probably substantial
overhead in the uh just the fact that
there's like python glue in the current
trainer but like that's on the the
docket right heck literally anybody can
go help with that like you don't even
need RL experience for that that's just
optimization stuff hell like if you
wanted to you could go look up like you
could go figure out for us like what uh
what flops are we pushing compared to
the actual flops the gpus are capable of
and then try to get that number to go up
matching clean Pop R yeah all you would
do is you'd go figure out what flops
your G the GPU is capable of right you'd
figure out how many flops training takes
you would have like a utility or
whatever to do
that and then you would compare the
current puffer throughput to that and
you'd look for
optimizations well the thing is
utilization is it's like on Nvidia SMI I
don't think that actually is going to
give you flops I think you actually have
to compute I mean there's a way that
people do it in llms like llm people do
this right they have like percent mfu or
whatever
maximum flop utilization something like
that so you'd actually like make sure
that the you'd actually have to go and
figure it
out but I wouldn't be surprised if we're
on like 30 to
60% of what we're uh capable of here I
really
wouldn't I mean there are all sorts of
things that people people can do around
um puffer lib that don't even require RL
experience like there are tons of just
like ml engineering and like General ml
research things that aren't really RL
specific um that we need people to do
because I basically I just do things as
I have time to do them right I just go
from like highest priority next highest
priority and so on but there are a lot
of things to do I mean I've been
onboarding Spencer and Captain for this
they've been two great contributors we
need more people
though just building
for Simplicity Jax has eaten this error
message please go Puck
yourself very helpful Jack thank you
well clean
paparel dedicated profiler yeah I would
just if I were doing this I would just
go look at what they do in llm
land and figure out how to do it for
hell Christ
almighty
why have you been interested in Jack
envir Jacks
environments uh I'm I hate Jacks it's
horrible I don't recommend anyone uses
it did something noteworthy happened
yeah we started a collab with Jacob
forester's Lab at NPS and then I
immediately got pneumonia afterwards so
that threw off everything and I just now
circled back around to it they have a
couple good jackm that they've already
written uh that I was just going to add
bindings for that doesn't mean I'm
making puffer lip Jacks it's just we're
doing bindings for existing jackm also
is it possible to create a jack torch
temper Bridge yes it's two lines of code
I've already done
it um yeah
so that's all that's happening
just adding some bindings for some
oh this is the uh the two lines of code
or whatever it's just DL pack which I
don't even know why this is a thing but
you just do this and then this and it
copies it over well it doesn't copy
it it just Bridges
oh come on conversion of multi- discreet
not
supported conversion of multi- discreete
supported to discreet them is off
you Contin us maybe then will you allow
me to do what I want
okay apparently specifying arguments is
uh pythonista for screw you we don't
care so let me figure this out
oh I'm stupid that's the problem problem
is I'm
stupid there we
[Laughter]
rapper D me
crazy I Love sample code that doesn't
work so
and it's crazy like me dealing with my
own code it's like with puffer lip code
it's like Zen it's easy tons of work
gets done very very quickly it's like I
can add whatever I want without having
to rethink a bunch of things it's really
short to sync it's fast and as soon as I
go anywhere outside of puffer it's
freaking
you know the compile time on Jack is
like just kick in the ass not only does
it make your code terrible but it makes
your code slow to make it
fast I think there is a way to run it
without the Jet right
no it's slow every time you have to
debug it is there a way to run it
without this incredibly stupid
jit why do I want the code to be slow
once I want it to be slow zero times
well don't you think debugging is a
rather important thing to not be
cursed I can tell you the reason this is
stupidly
designed yeah it's not about breakpoint
it's it takes forever to compile
anything as well so every time I think
there's a way to run it without the jit
um I don't even then maybe it's so slow
that nothing even worked I don't know um
I mean regardless the thing that's
stupid block until ready no this is just
like it just it's compiling so that it
can error like I
don't the thing that's really stupid
about Jax is it is a functional compiled
domain specific language in Python so
people say oh you can just write python
but this isn't python this is something
that is dramatically more convoluted and
complex than just writing [ __ ] in C but
it's like oh it's python it must be easy
no this is like the most insane thing
possible this is like the worst parts of
oop combined with the worst parts of
functional combined with a syntax that's
absolutely not designed for any of
jet is there no flag I can
pass to wrap the entire program in that
context seriously
I mean it's just bad is the thing this
is just bad and unless you have like a
very specific reason for using it like I
don't know maybe it's dramatically less
painful for uh parallelization since
it's just the like nothing to do with
Jacks but just it's the Google thing of
like oh yeah we build in for for scale
so it scales well or whatever like
unless you have very specific reasons
for using it it's just a stupid
framework to
Flags man I wish torch had like a pure C
really simple back end so if you really
wanted to optimize your networks instead
of having to wait for the torch compile
thing to take forever rapper you could
just like write the thing in C and have
your fuse
whatever there are five different ways
to disable the
I mean it's just really really bad is
the thing
compile compile causes pain in the ass
as well
the thing is you can't even be
embarrassed as a Jackson joyer because
this is the best that there is right
this is the most impressive project I've
seen in Jack by a mile
so this isn't the worst that Jax has to
offer this is the best Jax has to
this I think it takes longer without the
jet for
like this isn't entirely stupid in the
sense that yes humanoids are a good
midterm solution to stuff because
they're very general but like if your
idea is to replace people sorting
packages with robot sorting packages
instead of with just like an automatic
package sorder that's just incredibly
stupid like the final form factor of
everything is always going to be the
optimized per use case one
argument must be okay so that's
something uh that is
something it reset
man still on dude this thing is ass okay
this whole thing like all these like oh
RL is going to be so good now cuz it
went to Jack this is why it died cuz you
people chose something stupid to get on
to
next cuz you couldn't leave python you
had to keep it in Python you pick the
stupidest DSL ever as long as it looks
like
python Jack 2D is the quadratic in the
number of entities
linear you can make it suin your act
actually H you can make it close to
constant but this isn't me [ __ ] on
this project like quite the opposite
like I think this is probably the best
ja project out there in RL
like this guy is good it's just Jack his
ass puffer lib rigid body engine yeah no
we were thinking about it uh Captain
says that box 2D is pretty darn good for
what it is their C library and that it's
still actively developed and that
there's not much you'd want to do on top
of it I haven't really looked yet to see
if I agree but um I don't think we'd
want to do just 2D either if we were
going to do it because like we're going
to need 3D as as
well yeah when I review impulse Wars
that's going to be like a full day
review
one mil SPS grafts
brand I mean honestly does that even do
anything for
us like realistically what does it do
for us if we get
that I mean for like very specific
manipulation Manny skills pretty
good I don't think that that immediately
gets us like a million and annual
revenue somehow
right I don't think that it allows us to
really improve much in general RL just
very specific control robotic
stuff towards 2.6
420k much slow good but Captain is it
torch 2.6 or is it the Cuda
version can I ship can I ship torch 26
with Cuda 124 do you need higher Cuda
be I don't know are robotics customers
good some
are I'd way rather have a power grid
want me to optimize their like power
allocation or something that's a $10
million
contract that funds a lot of
bot are you kidding me we're back to not
implemented
error the space
it's
busy 121 26 I me I can go to 24 mean to
124 I can go to 124 no
problem I'd honestly like to upgrade it
with get us python 312 as
drivers the lowest Cuda version that
they ship auntu 24
on uh is higher than the one that you
can install without
ppas multiple cases of mcrip compile
code changing Behavior oh
lovely this is why we should just write
our own [ __ ] and be
looked into channels last pie
torch only fixed memory layout you have
to keep
channels it only affects memory
[Music]
layouts after badge
to what do you mean it only affects
memory
layout
God why is
this is a good stopping point for
tonight well a couple other things I
have to do but I want to just ask this
guy how to fix
why does it not let you paste a gift on
web but it lets you on mobile that's
stupid oh
whatever I really just wanted to check
on the Neptune runs and call it Neptune
runs we've now have several projects
around
Puffer that need
doing so I'm going to get stuff done
here okay so that bug is fixed I fixed a
major annoyance with sweeps that I
introduced I don't know a couple days
ago yesterday something like
that so we do this
this yeah now this is actually doing
something cool we'll have result for
this in the
morning uh this is more scattered than
it used to
be I guess but maybe this is still
good I don't
know we'll see this in the morning as
well these are both good these both have
active runs we're
happy a okay happy with
these cool
um I think that's it unless anybody has
anything else
yeah I'm going to go to bed um we'll
continue on step tomorrow uh I did get
some cool stuff though for today I got
there's a clean Dev Branch now it's got
sweeps it's got the new algorithm it's
got
e3b and a few other goodies in
it uh it's stable for the default policy
at least the new policies may or may not
need function signature
changes that we are going to defer until
we know which things we're actually
keeping in the new
repo um it also has the clean RL API
refactory a lot of good stuff in there
so I think the plan for the next several
days is to keep running experiments
refine the sweeps a bit make sure all
the M's work with sweeps and get ready
to like start really running large scale
experiments
and then we'll probably do some other
stuff like the lab collaborations and uh
client work you know just alternating
stuff so that I don't go insane from
having to deal with the same crap code
all day long for multiple
days um yeah and then we'll see after
that
so thank you folks if you're interested
in all the stuff I do buffer. a start
the repo please start the repo it really
helps like it really really helps it's
free it takes two
seconds other than that you can join the
Discord if you're interested in getting
involved follow me on X for more content
we've got a Blog here we've got all
sorts of fun
demos yeah so I'll